这个新人做自媒体 容易掉进三个坑
至少有一个
然然你觉得你没掉坑啊 你要赶快滑头 别浪费时间
首先我们第一个坑叫什么呢 就等
我看好多人都是想的是
我把粉丝坐起来以后
然后再算钱
我跟大家讲
做内容是一种能力
赚钱是一种能力
你不可能说我做内容做好了我这个赚钱那个能力就长出来了 只是不可能
我就是好多人
基本上大位
照不着钱 后来不做了
到现在为人还经常有百万大位啊 就联系我
想过请教说胡子哥我到底该怎么转钱
我给你九立了 就好像说
你开餐厅
刚开的时候呢
你觉得说亚人都来
把人都照过来 免费
是我的经历架构 吃 对吧
你看人来了以后你觉得可以了
大家都知道好了 我感受味道对不对
你所谓话就跑了 为什么
你别都是来办票的
这还不是就知道的 还有个更重要的东西
我以后再跟大家说 我们说第二个问题就另外一个计断了
你
就是内容没派两条 那就就就就就就交收费 交上钱
人家们人还没听到深守 交钱
你怎么好意思呢
这些好像两个谈压 谈压 谈他们两个钟 然后你跟人说
就要跟着他先把事办了
然后再慢慢
培养感情 你的臭流氓
这个确计确计 没有那个参成信任的时候 你就要收钱这
很糟糕的
然后这三种情况什么 就很厉必就不想
这天天想的是 我要做什么内容啊 我的身体是什么呀 我的暴管怎么做呀 我怎么撑热的呀 我一天要拍一拍 这种啊
就没想过到底该怎么 赚钱
这个其实是一种确实啊
我给大家说两个例子吧 就是我刚来短短视频的时候呢 我是真没想过这么转钱
就是明昊我拍了三年 没有任何就是转钱的产品
然后人家很多 然后每天我还去回乎
但是我发现 遇到一个什么问题的 就是他们会把我带篇
因为什么人上班都会给你留言 他有他的想法 他有想法 你然后你
他觉得这个想法你就不能那个去走了
我跟大家去过小里子就好了啊 就是你胸口是大事
在外边不行 您把一遍一脱 漏出漏出房子 打把胸口是大事
也会有人给你别在 给你 我是他给你叫好 也罗奔也有人给你点赞 给你叫好
他什么目的不知道 但是和网上一样啊 我告诉你流量看得很大 但那点流量对你来说一点帮助我没有收入认识 而且那流量不就是好流量
但是呢 当你开始真的收费的时候
人们会用真心白银给你投票 这个东西 真的是有价值的 当然 目的不是骗人啊 就是真的给别人提供价值的情况下
人家是用真心白银给你投票 所以各位体会一些这句话
收费不是内容的中脸
收费是做内容的信号 上面这个方向是对的
然后不在这个方向 不断的前几不断前几滚水球这个系统 越做越大
这三个可能看起来的好像是不太一样 但背后都是一个东西的折瘦的什么呢 就是
你不知道该怎么转钱 首先第一个很多人是不好意思转钱
不好一点 前几坦觉得转钱这个事好像上不了台面
我也不知道这个思想怎么来的 但是这个思想是很糟糕的思想 很多人都有
觉得转钱这个事上不了台面 当然有人想明白了说不行 我要转钱
而且有人也明白了转钱是有另外一种方式 就是给这个社会创造价值来活的财富的
但是想明白了 不知道该怎么转钱
这就是我们折瘦的很多人的问题 怎么办
怎么解决 我给大家说三个方法 三个方法 第一个问题 第一个方法就别挡
好嘚嘚在挡吗 但是我建议别挡 这个时候你要去想 我能给别人提供什么价值
谁是我的用户 或者是我本身会什么 我能帮助别人什么
谁是我的用户 这个一定要想 别挡
第二个 别急
本要也上来就就是想得转钱 你要建立信任 所以你可以把一些好东西分享给别人
然后建立建立信任 同时是在赛学用户
重要用户是要赛学院的 不是什么要的用户 都能靠你 你会发现
来很多人不一定是好事 他会忽然你
他会影响你 反而你应该去顾律一些人
让何时的人来到你的身边 这个时候人是很容易受外就环境影响的 所以第二个问题就是
我说的别急 就是你通过不得那个别人分享 来信一些
这个价值观啊 就是比较合适的人对了一个赛学人的过程 另外一个是建立信任的过程
不得给别人提供好东西
第三个问题是什么呢 就是你要去做产品
做产品 就是你要去西亚东怎么去做产品
不会不干就像我说的 你不是说你不做 他就慢慢就会长出来
就是你觉得能给别人提过什么价值 快速做出一个
小的东西来把粗糙一点 粗糙的产品
品版没在强巴有用的多 快速发出去 然后根据发生这个那种
然后来获得 反馈 然后再去改信 赚钱这个能力是一点 一点
张出来的
所以我跟大家讲 就赚钱这件事
他背后有两个东西 各位好好思考一下 第一个问题 当一不好一在赚钱的时候
其实背后有一个东西指费说的是你对自我价值的不认可
这是第一个 我们很多人确实的
我们来说第二个 我们很多人确实的是什么 用于承担责任的这个用气和担当
所以你不要于上来就想的赚钱 就就就要赚钱 但是你一上来就要用赚钱的
逻辑
三年事 第一 不要等
第二 不要鸡
第三
做产品